[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous venez d'être arrêté par la police
vous étiez en voyage aux etats-unis et
au bord d'une petite route on vous a
arrêté on vous a jeté en prison et
demain vous serez présenter un jeu gens
vous accusent d'un délit que bien sûr
vous pensez que vous n'avez pas commis
et là on vous explique que le juge va
d'abord décider si on vous libère sous
caution en attendant votre jugement qui
sera peut-être dans plusieurs semaines
ou si on vous garde au frais ce qui
serait peut-être bien d'ailleurs pendant
quelques temps enfin quand même vous
préféreriez sortir et voilà qu'on vous
dit cette décision de vous libérer sous
caution ou pas elle va être prise par un
algorithme car techniquement elle est
prise par un juge mais en fait il ya un
algorithme qui va étudier votre profil
qui va calculer le risque vous présentez
qui en fonction de ça va faire une
recommandation au juge est pratiquement
toujours le juge va suivre la
recommandation
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
ça vous inquiète un peu en général dès
que je parle des leurs ils s'achètent un
froid d'ailleurs mais on est très
inquiet dès qu'on nous parle
d'algorithmes l'année dernière en france
on a eu deux grands rapports sur
l'intelligence artificielle et le big
data
un fait par la cnil et l'autre par la
commission villani et les deux ont pris
le même exemple celui dont je viens de
vous parler d'un algorithme américain d'
aide à la décision judiciaire qui
s'appelle compass pour nous expliquer
dans les deux cas avec la même formule
d'ailleurs qu' il est très important que
l'homme garde la main qu'on ne laisse
pas les algorithmes décider à notre
place et c'est un sujet important parce
que dans tous les domaines de notre vie
les algorithmes prennent une place de
plus en plus importante si vous avez
passé le bac cette année c'est un
algorithme qui décide quelles études
vous allez faire et puis quand vous
aurez fini vos études vous chercherez un
job vous enverrez décédé c'est sans
doute un algorithme qu'il est rire a
ensuite peut-être même que l'entretien
que vous passerez si votre cd a été trié
sera analysé en vidéo par un algorithme
ça commence à être de plus en plus
fréquents puis si vous avez le job il
faudra une voiture pour y aller
alors il faudra que vous ayez un crédit
c'est un algorithme lui qui décidera si
vous pouvez avoir un crédit et puis il
faudrait vous preniez une assurance
c'est un algorithme qui fixera le prix
de la prime d'assurance et ainsi de
suite jusqu'au jour où vous serez
percutés par une voiture dont
l'algorithme aura décidé qu'il vaut
mieux vous tuer vous que vous puisqu'on
nous explique 116 que les voitures
autonomes vont être pilotés par des
algorithmes qui feront ce genre de
calcul bref on nous décrit sans cesse un
monde où on va être les victimes des
algorithmes un peu comme les passagers
du vaisseau de 2001 l'odyssée de
l'espace sont sous l'emprise de
l'ordinateur vous rappelez moi je
voudrais vous inviter à reconsidérer
cette vision à questionner cette
aversion aux algorithmes que nous avons
et peut-être même à changer d'avis sur
les algorithmes
qu'est ce qu'on reproche aux algorithmes
dans toutes ces histoires que vous
entendez la première chose qu'on leur
reproche très souvent c'est d'avoir des
billets vous avez entendu parler des
billets rythmique par exemple le fameux
algorithme compass dont je vous parlais
a été étudié par des journalistes de
propublica ce corps aux organismes de
journaliste d'investigation qui ont
démontré que l'algorithme est raciste
puisqu'il se trompent plus souvent au
détriment des noirs qu'au détriment des
blancs et plus souvent en faveur des
blancs qu en faveur des noirs
donc ce canal rythme qui est biaisé vous
avez peut-être aussi entendu parler d'un
algorithme de recrutement que amazon a
dû cesser d'utiliser parce que
l'algorithme étaient entraînés sur des
données existantes et que donc comme
amazon avait recruté beaucoup d'hommes
dans le passé bal al green préférer les
profils d'hommes aux profils de femmes
et donc l'algorithme était sexiste ou
peut-être que vous avez entendu parler
de ces algorithmes de reconnaissance
faciale qui sont assez bons pour
reconnaître les blancs mais qui sont
très mauvais pour reconnaître les noirs
bref il ya des algorithmes qui ont des
billets et soyons clairs c'est vrai ces
algorithmes même si certains de ces
exemples ont été exagérées ces
algorithmes biaisé existe il ya rien de
plus facile d'ailleurs que fabriquer un
algorithme biaisé mais quand on dit il
existe des algorithmes biaisé
et donc il faut se méfier tous les
algorithmes est-ce qu'on n'est pas en
train en fait de commettre exactement la
même erreur de logique que les racistes
qui utilise un stéréotype
on est en train en fait de reprocher aux
algorithmes de faire des stéréotypes en
utilisant un stéréotype pour les
algorithmes
c'est quand même un peu bizarre la bonne
question c'est pas est ce qu'il ya des
algorithmes biaisé bien sûr qu'il en a
la bonne question c'est est ce qu'on
peut faire des algorithmes qui ne le
soient pas ou qui en tout cas le soit
moins que nous ça veut dire qu'il faut
arrêter de se comparer à un idéal et
qu'il faut se demander ce que feraient
les humains auxquels on compare ses
algorithmes elle a fait intéressant
prenez par exemple les juges américains
puisque c'est d'eux qu'on parlait il ya
une étude sur les juges de l'immigration
aux états unis qui vous montre qu'il ya
des disparités considérables entre deux
juges qui pourtant ont à peu près la
même population de demandeurs dans un
cas extrême en floride dans la même
ville dans le même tribunal vous avez
deux juges auxquels les demandeurs
d'asile sont affectés aléatoirement
il y en a un qui accorde 4 % des
demandes
l'autre 90% c'est pas m'habiller sa
pensée que l'algorithme est pire et dans
tous les domaines où vous regardez le
jugement humain vous trouvez ce genre de
biais exemple au bureau des brevets
américains aiment dire les brevets ce
pas très grave m'enfin quand même si
vous êtes l'inventeur qui dépose un
brevet ça vous embête un peu de vous
dire que il ya des employés du bureau
des brevets qui donne deux fois moins de
brevets que d'autres plus embêtant si
vous avez à faire un jour au service qui
s'occupe de venir décider si vous êtes
un mauvais parent et si on va vous
retirez vos enfants pour les mettre dans
une famille d'accueil en fonction du
travailleur social qui vient chez vous
vous avez des écarts à la aussi qui vont
de 1 à 3 donc les billets des
algorithmes sont un vrai problème
enfin les biais des humains sont un vrai
problème aussi pour que les algorithmes
soit aussi biaisés que les humains
faudrait qu'il soit vraiment très très
très biaisée
ensuite on a un autre problème qui en
fait beaucoup plus important qui est que
même les humains les plus biaisée et
même les éloigner plus biaisée ne se
trompe pas seulement dans le sens de
leur bière le biais c'est une erreur
prévisible c'est une erreur qu'on commet
pour une raison mais on peut aussi se
tromper
sans raison prenez le recruteur sexistes
qui va recruter beaucoup plus d'hommes
que de femmes
déjà c'est une erreur mais vous pensez
que parmi les hommes il va recruter les
bons a priori si et pas très malin pour
commencer il ya pas de raison qu il
recrute les meilleurs hommes
il va se tromper aussi dans ses choix à
l'intérieur d'une catégorie et cette
erreur là cette erreur sans raison ou en
tout cas sans raison qu'on soit capable
d'identifier clairement c'est ce qu'on
appelle le bruit c'est l'erreur
aléatoire le billet c'est l'erreur
directionnelle explicable le bruit c'est
l'erreur qu'on sait pas expliquer
l'erreur aléatoire l'exemple le plus
frappant de bruit pour vous en donner
une représentation tangible c'est quand
on prend la même personne et qu'on lui
demande de faire le même jugement à
partir des mêmes données à deux moments
différents
il ya par exemple des études sur les
radiologues on leur montre une radio
qu'en fait ils ont déjà vu il ya
quelques mois par exemple les en ont vu
des centaines par jour depuis donc ils
se souviennent pas de la radio et dans
un nombre non négligeable de cas leur
jugement leur diagnostic sur cette radio
va changer entre les deux fois où ils
l'ont fait ou bien prenez un exemple
encore plus étonnant les les experts en
empreintes digitales quand vous leur
soumettait une paire d'empreintes
c'est-à-dire l'empreinte qui a été
relevé sur la scène du crime et puis
l'empreinte qui a été prélevé sur le
suspect en lui demandant de tremper son
doigt dans l'encré au commissariat vous
leur demandez est-ce que ça correspond
nous disent oui ou non vous leur montrez
la même paire d'empreintes quelques mois
plus tard là aussi ils en ont vu des
centaines d'entre eux tant dans un
nombre non négligeable de kara
statistiquement significatifs leur
jugement va changer donc ce jugement
humain qu'on croit fiable qu'on croit
stable en fait il a une grande
composante de bruit il a une grande
composante d'aléatoire pourquoi c'est
important parce que l'algorithme c'est
ça sa force lui il n'a pas de bruit
quand vous donnez à l'algorithme les
mêmes données ils vous donnent la même
réponse
donc il peut avoir des billets mais il
en aura moins que la plupart des humains
et surtout il aura pas de bruit donc il
va faire beaucoup moins d'erreurs que la
plupart des humains c'est ce qui
explique sa supériorité
mais je me sens pas convaincu
vous avez toujours pas envie que ça soit
un algorithme qui vous jugent sur le
bord de la route en louisiane ne sais
pas mais je crois que je sais pourquoi
c'est parce que l'algorithme on comprend
pas ce que c'est c'est opaque
c'est pas transparent soit dit en
passant le jugement humain non plus mais
quand on vous dit vous allez être jugé
par un homme ou par une femme
vous savez à peu près comment ça
fonctionne un algorithme ces mystérieux
c'est une boîte noire
en fait on vous demande d'aimer une
espèce de saucisse sans vous dire
quelles sont ces ingrédients et sans
vous montrez l'usiné où elle a été
fabriquée
c'est pas très appétissant en fait ce
qu'on voudrait c'est un algorithme qui
ressemble pas une saucisse mais qui
ressemble à une assiette de crudités bio
ou en sache exactement ce qu'on a devant
nous ça soit complètement transparent
mais peut-être que dans certains cas
c'est possible je reprends mon exemple
de l'algorithme compass ce fameux
algorithme de décisions judiciaires
américaines il est basé sur 137 critères
à ressasser du big data
on va triturer 137 informations sur
chaque prévenu
pour calculer un score de risque de
récidive est évidemment la formule qui
va faire ce calcul est secrète
puisqu'elle est la propriété de
l'entreprise privée qui met cet
algorithme à la disposition des
tribunaux des différents états
américains
donc c'est pas transparent du tout voilà
que deux chercheurs cinq chercheurs
d'ailleurs américain de stanford et deux
à noyau se disent et si on essayait un
truc si on prenait les deux critères
parmi ses 137 les deux paramètres
seulement dont on sait sur la base de
toutes les études de criminologie que ce
sont les meilleur prédicteur de la
récidive
qu'est ce que c'est l'âge du prévenu et
le nombre de condamnations qui l'a déjà
sur son casier judiciaire
qu'est-ce qu'on serait capable de
prévoir comme risque de récidive en
utilisant simplement ces deux paramètres
et en les combinant d'une manière très
simple de manière linéaire et bien avec
ces deux paramètres
il arrive à exactement la même fiabilité
de prévision que les 137 critères de
combat
vous avez avec ce small data avec très
peu de données avec une règle simple la
même qualité de prévision que vous aviez
avec les normes complexité de la
moulinette du big data et ça c'est
quelque chose que sur le principe ans et
en fait depuis très longtemps depuis une
soixantaine d'années
alors pourquoi on ne fait pas plus
pourquoi on voit pas du small data
partout pourquoi on nous parle tout le
temps de big data d'abord parce que ce
que je viens de vous raconter est un
exemple et que ça marche pas à tous les
coups il faudrait chercher mais aussi et
surtout je crois parce que quand je vous
dis que ça atteint le même score de
prévisions la même qualité d'exactitude
de deux scores de risque
de quoi on parle on parle de 65% dans le
cas d'espèce c'est à dire qu'on a des
algorithmes qui vont dans 65% des cas
prévoir qui va récidiver qui ne va pas
récidiver et qui dans 35% des cas se
trompent 65% c'est pas mal c'est un tout
petit peu mieux que les juges humain pas
beaucoup mieux
enfin on espère qu'on peut faire mieux
ce qu'on attend du big data c'est que en
changeant ses formules en apprenant plus
en s'entraînant mieux en améliorant les
algorithmes il arrive à 70 75 à 80 en
fait on rêve qu'il arrive à 100 la
promesse du big data
c'est qui nous dit qu'avec ces
algorithmes qui va arriver à une
prévision parfaite
c'est de ça qu'on rêve si on y réfléchit
deux secondes on voit bien que c'est un
rêve complètement irréaliste que jamais
on arrivera à voir un algorithme qui
prévoira avec 100% d'exactitude ni même
je pense avec beaucoup plus de 65 % le
risque de récidive devrait personne
humaine qui ont un libre arbitre
même dans minority report c'était pas un
algorithme qui faisait la prévision
c'était une espèce de créature magique
donc c'est un rêve qui ne se réalisera
pas mais c'est pourtant la quête de ce
rêve le fantasme de la machine
omnisciente capable de prévoir l'avenir
parfaitement qui nous conduit à vouloir
des algorithmes toujours plus compliqué
au prix d'une complexité et d'une
opacité de plus en plus grande qui crée
cette réaction de rejet que nous avons
face aux algorithmes
le small data où les règles simples
c'est le contre-pied de ce raisonnement
c'est de se dire que dans certains cas
dans beaucoup de cas on devrait faire
mieux que le jugement humain avec des
algorithmes simple totalement
transparent est évidemment un parfait
dont on accepte l'imperfection parce
qu'on préfère un petit peu plus de
transparence et peut-être que là quand
on aura un algorithme de ce genre là le
jour vous serez arrêtés sur le bord de
la route aux états unis et qu'on vous
dira que c'est un algorithme qui va
décider
vous direz bonne nouvelle parce que pour
que les algorithmes seraient nos amis il
n'y a pas besoin qu'il soit parfait il
ya juste besoin qu'ils soient meilleurs
que nous merci
[Applaudissements]